coronavirus isn't just a threat to your
health it's a threat to the economy as
infection numbers ticked up the stock
market had its worst day in 12 years so
it's probably not surprising that
President Trump has promised very
dramatic plans to help keep the economy
up and running basically we're talking
about a new stimulus but that just
raises a different question
can you really solve a public health
problem with economic policy with me
today to talk about the coronavirus
economy and what to do about it is
Veronique de Russia she's a senior
research fellow at the Mercatus Center
at George Mason University and a
frequent contributor to Reason magazine
so isn't this the government's job to
step in in times of economic crisis and
to help people out what is wrong with
president Trump saying that he wants
dramatic intervention measures so the
problem isn't so much that the
government would do something in terms
of emergency the question is what can
they really do and that's really
actually it's really the big question
because this is not an emergency like
like we've seen this is not the Great
Recession this is not an natural
disaster that keeps a whole city under
water it's very different it's a public
health issue with economic consequences
and it's kind of unclear what the best
way to go about it and unfortunately as
rahm emanuel said that you know it's
like you can't let a crisis go to waste
what you see is a lot of people pushing
policies that they've always supported
and using the koruna virus as a way to
push them through even though they
wouldn't actually have any impact let's
talk about some of those policies
specifically one of the big ideas that
people have talked about is a payroll
tax holiday this is something we've done
before in the aftermath of the Great
Recession and people are talking about
doing it again so basically on your
paycheck you you have deductions for
Social Security for Medicare those
deductions would go away for some period
of time this is a tax break people would
get more money on their paychecks what's
wrong with that so the problem with a
payroll tax cut
is how you're going to design it but
also what it's supposed to achieve so
one of the reasons why there could be an
economic problem right now it's not so
much because people don't want to spend
money or don't have enough cash but it's
because they actually are trying to
limit their commercial activities they
try to not go to the theater they're
trying to not go to the restaurant
they're basically they're not
cash-strapped they just basically
forcing some savings on themselves
because of the health issue so if you do
a payroll tax cut that is on the
employee side you're just really very
likely not going to be increasing the
incentive for people to interact more in
places where the virus they could catch
the virus on the employer side I mean
it's it's questionable I mean it is true
that a lot of small businesses that are
faced with a decrease in demand for
their products it may benefit from from
it but can the reduction be big enough
and fast enough to compensate for all
this loss in demand it's just hard to
see if this continues for a long time I
mean the kind of payroll tax really if
you would need is not something that
this government can afford right so it's
hard to make a case for fiscal stimulus
when goods aren't being produced and
people aren't leaving their homes to go
buy more stuff yeah exactly and but
again it's really important to
understand that the way fiscal stimulus
usually works is by changing people's
behavior and it's hard to see when the
reason why people aren't consuming
things is because they don't want to go
to stores they don't want to be because
they don't want to go to restaurants
because they don't want to be infected
they don't want to go to the movies
because they don't want to be infected
how giving them more money is going to
is going to
really create a kind of boost that is
needed and the same on the employer side
when the problem isn't so much that they
can't employ people who would be
unemployed right now but it's the fact
that customers are not coming to their
stores and buyer and buying their things
so it's just kind of it's hard to see
how that would really help
well what about another idea I've heard
a lot about recently which is basically
bailouts in particular for the service
sector and the Travis travel sector you
mentioned hotels and restaurants people
have talked about making giving money to
the airline industry the airline
industry is going to be hurt pretty bad
by this at least over the next couple of
weeks and probably over the next couple
of months and the and travel is very
important to a functioning economy is it
a bad idea for the government to step in
and make the airlines whole here to try
and keep them afloat they are a vital
part of the economy they're an important
part of the economy but on ice
everything goes to a halt which we're
not yet talking about this we're not
there but Italy is yeah Wow Italy I
think is has many other problems right
then so on this so exact unless they're
basically they put a band on anyone
coming in and and anyone leaving the
country or anyone traveling to other
states where we're not there yet
I mean the the airline industry may
actually not be in the short term the
priority I mean the the will the people
who are really hurt and who don't have
much padding right now are actually
small businesses or employees in
restaurants and bars who a big part of
their compensation is is people tipping
them but if people are not coming and
ordering drinks and then tipping tipping
them they're going to be feeling the
pain quite significantly and and very
quickly
we've tried fiscal stimulus before
actually it started in with George W
Bush in 2008 passed a 150 billion dollar
stimulus gave most Americans
about a $600 check as a result then in
2009 when President Obama came into
office there was an 800 billion dollar
stimulus that was distributed between
social spending infrastructure spending
and tax cuts what lessons can we draw
from those previous attempts at stimulus
that might be relevant now so there are
two things with that with a President
Bush stimulus it goes to the fact that
we were able to see it's completely and
effective to actually give people money
what so the reason is that it actually
doesn't change the incentives that
people have to work invest and save so
when you don't have when you don't have
policy that actually fundamentally
change the way people behave you don't
get the kind of structural changes that
you need that really boost the economy
the other thing is like actually when
you give people and in some of the Obama
administration stimulus we saw this with
it too is when you give people money at
the time where they are feeling
cash-strapped
or they feel that they have a lot of
debt what they do is they don't they
don't go and spend their money what they
do is if they save it it's not
necessarily a bad thing but it certainly
is not it means that the stimulus is not
working in the way those who designed it
intended it if you're trying to get
money flowing in the economy and then
people don't spend it it's not so we saw
this with President Obama with the
grants to the states and the states had
actually faced dramatic decrease in
their in their revenue base because of
the of the recession and they had big
budget gaps which they can't have and a
lot of the money that they got from the
federal government they used to patch
their their budget deficits they didn't
actually spend it to go and and hire
workers and and to just basically they
didn't spend it so that's one of the
things we saw we
with the Obama stimulus the other thing
that we know as a general rule with
stimulus is by the time the government
gets around to handing out the money and
to to just to give it to the states or
the different actors usually the economy
itself has started to recover that's one
problem so it's kind of like arguably
you know not as effective the the other
thing is it's often very poorly targeted
so when you have a recession a true you
know true recession the best way to
spend your money right is to actually
change the incentives but also go and
hire people in the unemployment lines
you would that's the way you get people
back to work you wanna and unfortunately
one of the things that we saw with the
Obama stimulus is actually that it ended
up being used for pay raises or for
displacing workers who already had jobs
to go do other jobs that this time
around was supported by government money
and and that just doesn't really help
address the the economic situation so if
I'm hearing you right tax cuts don't
really work giving people money doesn't
really work bailouts don't really work
what does what should we do well they so
tax cut depending on how the design
could work sometimes but in a situation
like the corn a virus it's it's hard to
see how it's going to work because it's
not it's it's a public health issue so I
just but it's also an economic issue
it's an economic issue what else issue
has an effect III agree but because it's
a public health issue you're going to
have a very hard time telling people who
are staying home and not spending money
to actually go and spend money
even if you give them if you throw more
cash at them so it's not about injecting
money into the economy what should we do
then what company makers do to combat
what looks like the start of a recession
it's hard to tell in this case but one
thing that if you wanted to give and
president Trump loves giving adult a
positive jolt to the stock market he
seems to be just very in tune with what
the stock market is doing and and one
way to get the stock market going at
least for a little while would be for
him to announce that he's going to
unilaterally get rid of all his tariffs
that would have a positive effect on the
stock market for sure and and I assume
that it would actually get you know
China to get rid of its tariffs and then
the Europeans and and pretty much every
country around the globe now this is not
the ultimate solution to every economic
problems that we have because of this
public health crisis but certainly it
would give a job to the drop to the
stock market one other idea that people
have talked about is is paid leave
people have said that if we had a paid
leave program in place that that would
help people have money while they stayed
home from work which is what they need
to do when there is a pandemic is that a
good idea well there's always a problem
was pushing a permanent solution for a
temporary problem so in this case I
would say no it's it's not a good idea
and the other problem is pushing a
universal paid leave policy at the
federal level for for this particular
crisis would be problematic
I mean 75% of all workers in America
have paid sick leave already and 40% of
of
part-time workers also have paid sick
leave so in order for paid sick leave
policy put in place as an emergency and
in a temporary basis you would have to
really actually target it to these
workers
in particular if that is the case if you
can actually contain it to those workers
who don't have it there's there's a
value to it and I'm not opposed to the
government in terms of extreme emergency
doing things like this as long as it's
clear it's temporary if you really what
you want to stop the spread of the virus
is to keep sick people home you know
that could you know help a little bit
that said it may not help as much as we
hope for in absence of widely available
tests for the virus and because what
happens is like the you know the the
symptoms don't appear between two of and
14 days so you have this you know almost
two weeks to spread the virus around
after that yeah sure it'd be useful but
again there's a big difference between
trying to push a system a permanent
policy for this temporary crisis and or
putting in place a temporary measure and
the other problem with with this by the
way is if you don't target it to those
who do not have paid leave what you're
going to end up having is a system where
effectively you're shifting the
responsibility of those companies who
were providing paid leave privately to
the taxpayers because as we've seen in
states that have adopted paid leave
policy those companies usually starts
telling their employees to first use the
state-based policy and then they'll fill
the gap with theirs yeah this just seems
like an example of what you were talking
about before which is that people are
using this too as an opportunity to push
policies that they already believed in
in some cases that might make sense as
with in in terms of trade and that being
a temporary jolt to eliminate tariffs
but it seems like what we really need to
do is solve the public health problem
and and treat this as a public health
problem first and to that extent you
know a temporary
emergency provision of sick leave to
those who don't already have it could
help to some extent veronique thank you
so much for speaking with me today
you're welcome
thank you for having me